so as he told you one of the accounts on
Twitter that we just learned was
shadowband very aggressively was an
account called Libs of tick tock now
there's a reason they censored it
because it's one of the most important
accounts on Twitter
there are very few opinions expressed on
this Twitter feed it is almost entirely
video real video no one disputes it as
Real showing what is happening inside
classrooms where children are being
taught hospitals where your loved ones
are being treated all over the country
so Twitter on the basis of what
justification none prevented lives of
tick tock from trending that means many
people never saw what lives of tick tock
posted according to Barry Weiss an
internal Twitter Memo from October of
2022 after Libs of tick tock's seventh
suspension admitted that the account
lives with Tick Tock was not breaking
any rule the memo said this quote
acknowledge that lives with Tick Tock is
not directly engaged in behavior
violative of hateful conduct policy
so they didn't actually do anything
wrong
but Twitter sensors kept censoring and
Shadow Banning the account Loops of tick
tock anyway because according to the
memo Libs of tick tock quote either
leads to or intends to incite harassment
specifically against hospitals that are
castrating children
now that memo was prepared by Twitter
senior leadership including a CEO and
head of legal for Jag Gotti the person
who runs Libs of tick tock joins us now
by phone I sure appreciate your coming
on so
um you must have had some sense that you
were being well you were suspended
multiple times but you're being censored
in ways they weren't telling you did you
did you sense this was happening
hi Tucker great to be back
um yes I absolutely sensed that I was
being sponsored I have a very large
account
um
no I never was able to Trend and now we
find out I was on a trend Blacklist
there were sometimes days or weeks at a
time where I felt like my tweets were
getting much less engagement than usual
than they should and I think now it's
clear that there was suppression and
there were Shadow Banning
what's so infuriating about this
specific example is that you were
reporting I mean you weren't and and our
viewers can verify this for themselves
or they just go on to your account
you're you're not actually putting a lot
of your own views in here you're
disseminating reported material whose
authenticity no one doubts so you're
doing what the New York Times claims it
does but you're actually doing it unlike
them what could possibly be the
justification for censoring you
well I think it's clear that they're
used when spread they don't send off to
scrutiny and
um when I spread their views in their
own words they don't want you to see it
because they don't sign up to scrutiny
and it makes them look bad and that's
what they're really scared of and the
craziest part of this whole thing is
that they admitted that I'm not even
violating the policies and they still
suspended me seven times seven times
three of which were for a week at a time
so I was suspended for probably a month
altogether and for what for not even
violating their policies just because
they don't like their own views they
don't want you to see it that's exactly
right they were hiding you exposed them
they crushed you and we should say this
is not a hobby I mean you've devoted
your life to this we're glad that you
have
um we will talk to you soon Libs of tick
tock good to see you subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight